hello everyone hi as I'll do and hope
you guys are having a wonderful day
today we're here with another video and
today's video will be looking back on
raids items in old school runescape now
there's a lot to explain here and I mean
I'm going to try to do as best as I can
with this basically raids are something
that was introduced into the game at the
beginning of the year January so I've
been about eight or nine months now and
we kind of have a lot of information now
basically raids are the next tier
content within the game they were a
really big step and basically you can
expect more of this in the future so be
prepared the way games like this work
and games like runescape is if they're
willing to introduce something like
raids that improves content for certain
things they'll eventually do it for
others and with that said over time
we'll see new and better items come into
the game that will be worth a ton so
what we're going to be doing today is
looking over the grass and trends that
we saw with a majority of these items
and I'll be analyzing what info you guys
can take away from the charts and graphs
that we see a day and employ those upon
new items that enter the game in the
future
now while this may seem strange at first
because to the regular person you
wouldn't assume that the way raids items
go isn't necessarily the way most items
will go that is true however for the
most part these do show some really good
trends as far as what the community
thinks whenever items start to drop they
panic sell they buy and really just the
way stuff bounces back so that's I'm
going to go ahead and show you guys
today along with that I plan on telling
you guys a decent amount of tips as to
what to look for when you are actually
buying and investing into these items as
you guys can see here I have three
dragon claws on me I'm invested in those
I spent 200 and like 15 mil on it so
basically I'm going to go ahead and talk
to you guys about what I do when I see
these items alright and here we are with
the first item this is the code I wann
currently 118 mil which is actually
really impressive that it held such a
good value over this long of time so if
we go ahead and look back I lost a ton
of money at the beginning of code I want
because I was tried flipping them that's
my own fault we're not going to talk
about that but what we will be talking
about is kind of analyzing what the
graph says here now within three weeks
of having the code I want out and
hitting 88 mil it seemed like a pretty
much like you know almost for certain
type of merch because eighty eight mil
for the new best mage item in the game
that people still want to use there's
for mage it's obviously going to go back
up and it did but then to hit 60 ml I
thought at the time was astounding and
this is what we have to be careful of in
this instance is that a lot of times
whenever people start to see an item
drop especially it you know if it's a
decently new item people pile on and
just start selling just mass selling the
item because they're scared they don't
know what it's worth and that's the one
thing that you really need to be able to
try to make up for yourself so as you
guys can see here code I want hit 60
male 60 mil for the best weapon in the
game as far as maging is concerned it's
actually just I mean it's insane but you
also have to consider the fact that
raids are so hard to do like while 60 ml
may seem like a lot for maybe a good
item like you could be like oh well I
mean whips one of the best melee items
in the game but is only 1.5 to 2 mil
well that's because it's a lot easier to
go and kill some abyssal demons and
people do it in general just because
they have to for Slayer with something
like this you're going out of your way
literally just to make money and this
money making method has to be better
than Zora because you it requires so
much out of you it requires so much
knowledge as far as the minigames
concerned and it requires so much
knowledge in form of the game itself so
that naturally is going to make this
money making method a lot better so
while we nosed over can be upwards of 2
mil an hour you also have to take into
account that raid should then be at
least 3 mil plus and at the time is
around 4 to 5 so items really can't fall
like this especially really high price
items like I think a lot of items with
raids have held their value really well
because of the fact that Zola is such a
good money making method that you almost
have to keep these items at high prices
or else people aren't going to go and do
raids now as far as why this item
actually hits so low and then raised
back up all the way this it probably
isn't something you could really see I
mean personally I think without it it
probably be around 70 to 80 ml but
basically what happened during this time
was neck reels and dust devils became
really popular slayer test just became
the only thing you should really be
doing and with that a lot of high
efficiency people obviously are then
going to drop the money on a coat eye
wand and on top of that it had a really
high spike whenever the inferno was
released really no way to prepare for
that but some things you have to imagine
is whatever new content Jagex puts into
the game
something like mage that's going to be
insane you do have to think what are
they going to do to actually make this
content useful because whenever this
came out code I wands and everything
like that weren't all that useful in
mage and so you kind of have to
anticipate that they may do something
with it now on to the one and only
twisted bow I can't say I've flipped any
of these personally however there are
some things to learn from from here
basically right off the bat we'll say
that this weapon was one point one mil I
mean obviously higher upon the day of
release but you know around that time
one point one bill and that seems like a
fairly reasonable price well it is
really really expensive and I understand
that if you think about it it is going
to be the best weapon and it was known
at the time it's going to be the best
weapon in-game at certain bosses just by
far like without a doubt and so when you
have that it's obviously going to be
worth more than a bill and I say
obviously in quite a strange way I'm
sure but if you think about it
Alijah is used to be 750 mil if we go
back and check their price chart you
guys can see that they actually were 700
mil plus I mean before the whole divine
thing came out before the twisted bomb
before all of that they were really
expensive back here and if people are
willing to pay 733 mil for the best item
in game defensively think how much more
they'll be willing to pay for the best
item offensively so what's that even
buying a twisted bill so with that even
buying a twist about 1.1 bill seemed
like a really good investment and
obviously it turned out to be as the
hype kind of built up over that time and
Jags made various changes with a bow now
with that said over time it did hit one
point for bill and then there was a huge
scare and it dropped to 977 mil now I
remember that time that was incredible
but if we keep going it just kept going
back up and the reason they have to
think about this is I mean more and more
money's coming into the game every day
and if people are willing to spend 700
mil on the shield as I said before
obviously it's going to go back up but
the thing is that you have to kind of
consider here there are different highs
and lows for this item obviously because
it has such a high price and there's
it's really hard to put a price tag on
an item that's this rare and that's this
good but ways that you can logically go
about doing that it's saying hey this
bows worth Emmy at this time probably
dipped took 950 mil if I can get 950 mil
for the best item in game and people you
a 754 the best offensive item in game
that blood alone is worth it and would
have proved to be a really good
investment that's something you also see
here is whatever stuff like this dips
really hard it almost has an immediate
comeback then this is true with a lot of
the items here while it may not be
substantial and it may not bounce up
hundreds of mils as you guys can see
July 28th which was just two to three
weeks ago
you can see that the twist about 867 mil
and that is just absurd so obviously it
was going to go back up and this is a
trend that you see in a lot of graphs
with these new rate items this is how a
lot of this stuff just works people the
prices on new items are oftentimes made
by how people are like how scared people
are not the actual value of the item
this is just prime example I mean
obviously at the beginning 150 mil and
then just shoots up extremely extremely
high because people all think that this
is going to be some of the best stuff in
game now over time this is going to be
something that probably you could tell
what's going to have a bubble because
for the full set it's just a mage set
and at the time when this is 2:30 the
the row bottoms are probably like 140
the hats like 50 you're paying 400 mil
first set and not a lot of people in
game are willing to pay 400 mil just for
a mage set now if you consider the coat
I wand as well
being a hundred mil or maybe you know
around there at the time if you're
spending 500 mil just on maid gear and
mage isn't even the best form of attack
in the game in most places it obviously
has its spots and Slayer but outside of
that really this gear is pretty useless
with the twisted bow you have infinite
uses for that that's just insane
everywhere so obviously this was going
to drop from 230 now when it drops from
230 in two weeks to 138 that's your time
to buy that's I mean that's just its
prime its prime pickings I mean but the
problem is in that you have to notice
this for pretty much every update that
comes out and every new item that comes
out is there's going to be unless
something strange happens the way that
most items go is initially they're worth
more and over time they become worth
less and less and so you really have to
pick your spots right and it's hard to
really lose if something drops
unnecessarily 80ml with
two weeks it's pretty much a guarantee
just invest into it and it will go back
up especially an item this good now with
that said it's not going to hold that
price forever you have to do you do have
to dump it at the right point if you
don't do that you may be stuck with it
and as you guys can see it will fall on
you but that's what's going to naturally
happen over at eight to nine months span
and which these items are constantly
coming into the game and this is kind of
what makes me think that dragon claws
right now are a really good investment
but I will talk about their graphs as
well dragon claws are quite a weird one
and this is something that you would
have had to known right off the bat
obviously dragon claws are going to be
an insanely popular item at the
beginning and this is something that you
know is well well understood I would say
by anyone I was merging it or at least
knew what they were doing and merging it
dragon claws are such a throwback item
that people are going to want at the
beginning they're going to want it for
YouTube they're going to want it just to
experience what it's like and with that
said at the beginning it's going to be
worth an extreme amount because there's
a lot of Appeal to the item but after
time I mean dragon claws aren't a
practical item outside of PvP other than
maybe being one of the best DPS back
weapons in the game but I mean paying
200 300 mil for spec weapon obviously
what is not something that you plan on
doing now with that said dragon claws
have seen their fair share of dips and
raises during this time as you guys can
see they did dip originally to 110 mil
then went back up to around 140 this was
something that was probably going to
happen because if you assume dragon
claws three months in or only 110 mils
it's very easily accessible to a lot of
the game I guess not a majority of
players probably but a decent amount of
players have 110 mill and they're
willing to spend on it so that naturally
crawled their price back up however
since then they've been dropping and
even over the last month as you guys can
see there's been an insane drop and I
mean most drops I consider to be you
know decently understandable with dragon
claws because the items only worth it
for their PvP appeal value and stuff
like a GS takes this natural route to
where at the beginning of the game the
really crazy weapon that everyone wants
to PK with so it's going to be really
really expensive at the beginning but
over time it start to fall and that I
mean the d claws will in the future be
worth less than 70 mil I will agree on
that however to be dropping from 91 like
a steady 91 for like three weeks and
then
in the span of two weeks not even to
drop from ninety all the way to 70 mil I
thinks absolutely insane
but I think they'll come back and that's
kind of where I employee these
strategies now one thing I do want to
talk about is quite a weird item and
this is just going to be something that
you know you got if you got to figure
out yourself I'll give you all the tips
I can for this and I'll try to explain
it to its fullest now we have the dins
bulwark now this is a really weird item
there was a lot of stuff going on where
people thought that this was going to be
extremely useful and that there was
going to come a time where it would
actually have its place in the game now
that times coming past and it's really
not useful anymore
people realize dps is worth it way more
than the shield ever would be worth
doing anywhere but one thing that I will
say is with stuff like this be really
skeptical like right off the bat you
know really cool item it was tanky so
people were like maybe it'll be cool but
over time you can kind of predict an
item that's tanky never really works in
runescape it's I mean they even they've
had Giants has had a hard time trying to
get defensive items to actually be
something that people want that people
are willing to use because they employ
it in such a bad strategy and I think
the combat system of the game is
partially to be at fault for that now
with that said right off the bat you
guys can see this item dips really low
from 12.8 it started out over 100 ml
obviously because it's a new item it's
crazy people want to try it out but tips
to 12.8 and then has it's raised now
while it has its rise here a lot of that
was due to the fact that whatever the
inferno came out people think well you
know maybe the bulwark is going to be
useful maybe there will be stuff that
you'll need this bulwark for and that's
something I want to tell you guys
because whenever you see an item like
this something like the bulwark Giants
put into the game specifically to make
it so that this item has a place in the
game and while it is quite weird to talk
about it because it didn't happen
basically if something's put into the
game to having you something like this
you would think you know James is going
to make a use for it they will put in
some sort of content that will make this
useful and while that never happened
really
you can always whenever you see this
item drop really low you can buy it in
the hopes that you know at some point
maybe there will be whispers about it
maybe people will just start to think
that
at some point Jax has to put something
into the game for it and while that may
not necessarily be true even if people
think it might happen as you guys can
see here the prices will rise and you'll
be able to make money off of it now with
that said it at this point it's looking
pretty poor to be honest Jegs hasn't
really done much with the bulwark they
haven't really cared about it they
haven't tried to help it but it could be
something in the future that while it is
a six mil item now it's a really hard
item to get and if it ever has a real
significant use in the game it could
shoot up to 20 to 30 mil easily and it
would hold that price because they come
into the game so seldomly alright so
that will be as far as that goes
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video
basically my whole goal of this was to
try to tell you guys what I think
happens throughout the entirety of these
like these items lifespan in the market
and just try to make sense of everything
that's happened so that you guys have
information going forward as far as what
you could expect with different items
when Jetix eventually releases new
content for higher to your players now
while that may not be tomorrow there are
good strategies and good tips here that
hopefully you guys took in and will be
able to employ in the future going
forward but if you guys enjoy the
content make sure to leave a like if
there's anything you want to tell me
make sure to comment down below if you
guys want to show me a little bit of
support subscribe to the channel also
check out the clan chat in-game largely
XP lamp oh god I gotta join it there
large exp lamp with two E's also twitch
Twitter discord all in the description
down below so with that said hopefully
you guys have a wonderful day and peace
[Music]